après jeune Campion en 1993 pour la
leçon de piano et Julia Ducournau en
2021 pour titane Justine triée se hisse
sur le podium avec son film anatomie
d'une chute la première fois que je suis
venu c'était en 1963
il n'y avait aucune femme réalisatrice
en compétition et tout le monde trouvait
cela normal cette année le pays a été
traversé par une contestation historique
extrêmement puissante unanime de la
réforme des retraites la marchandisation
de la culture que le gouvernement
néolibéral défend est en train de casser
l'exception culturelle française est-ce
qu'elle est dans son rôle quand elle
fait ça je ne sais pas si elle est dans
son rôle
ce qui est certain c'est qu'elle a
raison sur le fond je pense que dans le
discours de Justin trier il y a
clairement un fond idéologique d'extrême
gauche je respecte ces positions elle a
elle a visiblement cette cet
argumentaire en tête parce que on reçoit
des financements publics on n'a pas le
droit de critiquer la politique de
l'État c'est ça le sujet enfin quand je
vois que les ministres du gouvernement
lui tombe dessus aujourd'hui
sous-entendu avec l'argent public que
vous avez vous feriez mieux de la fermer
je trouve ça scandaleux moi j'aimerais
bien qu'elle me donne les chiffres les
faits sur lesquels elle se base pour
que aujourd'hui la culture est
marchandisée et l'exception culturelle
cassée ça me rappelle la célèbre phrase
de Maurice Druon il faut choisir entre
la Sébille et le cocktail monotov et ben
c'est pas digne des ministres de la
Culture la soirée c'est poursuivie sur
le terrain politique de nombreux
responsables de gauche applaudissant la
prise de parole de Justine Triet par
exemple Jean-Luc Mélenchon merci à
Justine Triet pour son courage en plus
de son talent Cannes revient à sa
tradition c'est la gauche résistante qui
a créé ce festival on ne peut pas voter
sur cette réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale on n'a pas eu de
vote on a eu un 49-3 on manifeste dans
la rue on n'est pas entendu et on
s'exprime quand ors sont un prix on se
taper sur les doigts vous nous dites où
est-ce qu'on peut parler rassemblement
national il met les formes mais je pense
continuer à penser que c'est une
idéologie dangereuse
héritier de Peter oui également
Eric et Marine Le Pen pareil je je pense
que je n'ai jamais entendu Marine Le Pen
dénoncer ce qu'on peut être les
positions historiques de de son parti
c'est stupide de dire ça je veux dire on
a besoin d'apaisement on a besoin de
propos aussi caricatures que ça et
pourquoi elle ne dit pas je suis pas le
Parti communiste héritier de Staline ou
du pacte germano-soviétique ce serait
pas très intelligent mais ce serait pas
plus intelligent que ce qu'elle dit là
je crois que Élisabeth borne est à la
fois inculte indigne et incapable ces
problématiques quand on est oui c'est
problématique quand on est premier
ministre je vous l'accorde si Marine Le
Pen est élu c'est à cause d'elle c'est à
cause de notre première ministre parce
que tout moi chez moi il y a plein de
gens qui votent pour Marine Le Pen
caricature continuait à caricaturer
comme ça Marine Le Pen et ça exaspère
les gens vous avez compris et moi je ne
fais pas à Madame borne le procès
d'avoir servi une administration dont le
chef était à l'époque François
Mitterrand qui avait reçu la francise
que je ne dis pas que Madame borne a un
rapport avec tout cela donc je pense
qu'elle est inculte et je rappelle quand
même que la dernière fois qu'on a vu un
salut nazi à l'Assemblée nationale
c'était monsieur ribeirotte député la
Renaissance qu'il a fait raconter ce que
vous avez dit Marine Le Pen et j'avais
trouvé ça un petit peu qu'est-ce qu'elle
vous a dit Marine Le Pen choquant elle a
dit que je ne méritais pas d'être
ministre pose des Français
du tout ça
a l'air de La Baule Franck l'ouvrier dit
à voir reçu un courrier une enveloppe
anonyme avec cette mise en garde ça
pourrait être à La Baule traduite dans
un même envoi par des photos de la tête
des capitaines
par une autre du massacre du Bataclan
en soulignant que ce pourrait être à La
Baule un scandale en Inde d'après qu'un
responsable a décidé de faire vider ce
barrage pour récupérer son smartphone il
avait fait tomber l'appareil alors qu'il
se prenait en selfie 2 millions de
litres d'eau ont ainsi été gaspillé de
quoi irriguer 600 hectares de culture le
téléphone a été retrouvé il est
évidemment
inutilisable l'homme lui a été suspendu
de ses fonctions